Do you have any thoughts about using a continuous glucose monitor to see how food and fasting
affect your blood sugar?
Have you helped anyone analyze this info?
And are there any sources you know of for the monitor?
The one program I saw is $198 a year for the amp and $100 per quarter for the monitors.
So the benefits of using a continuous glucose monitor is that you don't have to prick the
fingers.
But it's really meant for someone who has to monitor their glucose so closely because
they're diabetic.
Wouldn't it be handy to have because you can see how food affects your glucose?
Yeah, kind of.
You want to do some of your own self examination and experimentation, but the problem is most foods
are going to spike your glucose.
That's just how your body reacts.
That's why when you do test glucose to monitor your glucose balance, you're testing a
12 hour or 10 hour fasting glucose because after you eat your glucose should spike up.
And then it goes back into balance.
Now the benefit of a glucose monitor would be could be for someone who's hypoglycemic
too because their person's hypoglycemic eats a meal, their glucose spikes and it drops
way low and it too low and they end up have symptoms of hypoglycemia.
That can be just as big of an issue of people that have diabetic issues.
So those people have to eat a lot of small meals in order to keep their glucose balanced.
But as far as just with cancer and experimenting to see what foods I eat spike my glucose,
it would be fun analysis, but I don't know that it's necessary.
Okay, your glucose was 105, not 205, well that makes all the difference in the world.
So a glucose of 105, fasting glucose of 105, yeah, cancer patient wants to get their
fasting glucose down into the 70s, ideally, right?
So I have information on the homepage of the member site about that.
So 105, yeah, that's still high, it's not diabetes, no, it's still high though.
So I would maybe wait, that's still what I've investigated.
You're been eating really well, you know, your glucose is still 105, I don't know your full
history of yours, you're at a history of diabetes or a history of pre-diabetic.
Maybe that, you know, looking at past glucose levels could be beneficial.
Also, it could have been just that day, that's why getting a glucometer and checking it on a regular
basis might be helpful for you. They're not very expensive. So a glucometer is, you know,
maybe $40, $50, how's 50 strips or 100 strips that come with it? So that's affordable to do to
go to check that out.